what if any changes Did You observe in
Amber over the period of her
relationship with Johnny
at First Amber was
Amber she was
she was loud fun funny she laughed a lot
she uh was just this happy bright
fun-loving thing always surrounded by
friends and then it just it was a
progression that took over such a long
period of time and it was so slow
in hindsight it was like watching a slow
motion gunshot she suddenly stopped
sleeping as much she wasn't as funny she
wasn't as loud she wasn't as gregarious
as she used to be
cut to the end of their relationship she
was so physically unwell she maybe
weighed 100 pounds soaking wet she was
emaciated she wasn't sleeping
she had developed the heart condition
and her eyes were sunken in she just
looked like she's a different Lac
Foundation calls her hearsay
she's giving her observations heart
condition I'll sustain us to Heart okay
other than the heart condition please
continue
uh she just if you were to do a
photograph side by side you would see
two very different people
and people that knew her throughout the
entirety of their relationships all the
same thing I went down there to talk to
him and again I can I can tell he's
clearly drunk and he has a bottle of of
alcohol some sort in front of him as
well
and again he's talking to me about how
he how Amber found these text messages
between him and a woman uh called
Rochelle and then he started saying that
this woman was meaningless I was just it
wasn't anything special she's nothing
special but then he immediately shifted
to well Amber Amber pushed me Amber made
me do it yeah of course I'm cheating on
her you know whatever and it suddenly
became about Amber making him do it
um at some point then Amber is on the
mezzanine level of pH five so she is
it's kind of hard to explain it's the
kitchen's down here and the mezzanine's
up here
so she's there it's her little office no
can she starts shouting at him uh saying
the objection you're on or hearsay it's
not to prove the truth of the matter
asserted your honor she's screaming
expletives at him I mean that's not
often right thank you
they're saying horrible things to one
another
you you know he's calling her
used up trash bag you know whatever they
were saying horrible things to one
another she was calling him old and fat
it was a fight they were saying really
nasty things to one another
I leave them in the kitchen to go up the
stairs I was trying to
call Amber down hopefully get her back
into my apartment and Debbie had come up
with me yeah and Debbie who's Debbie
Debbie was his nurse Debbie Lloyd uh yes
I believe that was her name
um so we're with Amber on the mezzanine
level I'm sorry just so we know who
where is is it you and Debbie that are
with Amber or yes Debbie Debbie Amber
and I are on the little mezzanine area
um and as I mentioned the mezzanine
looks overlooks the the kitchen in the
living room so
Johnny then hurls a Red Bull can and it
hits Debbie in the back she didn't even
react she didn't really seem to notice
um but I'm I'm standing up there talking
I'm standing up there I'm at the top of
the stairs with my back to the stairs
and that's when Johnny runs up the
stairs and my again I'm facing Amber he
comes up behind me strikes me in the
back
kind of just somewhere over here he
strikes me in the back I hear Amber
shout don't hit my sister she smacks him
lands one and then he grabs at that
point that's when Travis runs up the
stairs after Amber landed one and but by
that time Johnny had already grabbed
Amber by the hair with one hand and was
whacking her repeatedly in the face with
the other as I was standing there Travis
pulls them apart I get Amber into mine I
close the doors behind me and lock them
I then hear Johnny's voice shouting a
never mind Twitter sorry I hear Johnny's
voice shouting you I hate you I hate you
both
and I hear crashing you're crashing and
banging and smashing and he starts
screaming like an animal
and I then just moved Amber into the
next room and I just kept her there all
night the next day I go and I see her
closet has been completely destroyed
um racks were overturned yeah one of the
closing clothing racks have been like
tossed down the stairs there was Art off
the wall
um and down in the kitchen there was
broken glass like it just the place was
destroyed after the staircase incident
uh what if anything did Mr Depp ask you
to sign
there was an NDA on my kitchen table can
you tell the jury what an NDA is it's a
non-disclosure agreement it's basically
my understanding is it's a contract to
keep things private to keep your mouth
shut essentially
all right and you were given one or
asked to sign one I was asked to sign
one
um I don't I did I don't believe I
signed it I left sometime after so you
moved out after that
it was yes it was after this point that
Johnny had accused me of selling stories
to the media which
were absolutely untrue but I moved out
after that point he testified that you
had suspicions that Mr Depp was
allegedly hitting your sister by some
point in 2013 right
suspicions
and notwithstanding that in June 2013
you were actually joking with Mr Depp
about hitting your sister right
regrettably over a text message yes you
are encouraging him to hit her
I was not literally encouraging him to
hit her but you were joking about it
regrettably yes again Lex
I did not have an understanding fully of
what that was I never would have said
that now knowing what I know
but that was a legend that was around
the time that you allegedly became aware
that he was
I don't know injuries on your sister
that caused you to have suspicions I
don't know if it was around the same
time
turning to the um the staircase incident
in March 2015
um you testified that Mr Depp allegedly
hit you during that incident right
yes but you weren't sure if that contact
was even meant for you right I honestly
don't I don't know what he was aiming
for my back was to him and you weren't
injured during that incident right no I
wasn't and you didn't seek medical
attention
no
and you said Debbie Lloyd was there
during all of that correct she was and
Mr Depp's security Travis mcgivern was
there too yes he was
and you saw your sister hit Mr Depp on
the stairs that day right
after he struck me yes
you said she she landed one right
and then the next day you found some
damage in the adjoining Penthouse
correct and we saw some pictures of what
you saw that day right yes
you thought it was important to document
that damage right not to document
um it was Kevin's job to kind of clean
up the houses take care of the houses I
took pictures just so he could be aware
of what he would need to bring
um I didn't know if he had tools here or
whatever I was just preparing him for
what he was going to have to fix but you
didn't take any pictures of your sister
that day right
no I didn't
now after March 2015 you continued to
have a close relationship with Mr death
right
yes and you still love them
of course
and you were there for him if he needed
you right
of course
and in fact just a couple of weeks after
that staircase incident you were still
acting as the marriage counselor weren't
you
at some point sure
and uh that fall after the staircase
incident October 2015
um you claim you had seen Mr debb
hitting your sister and then in October
2015 you were actually still trying to
reconcile him and your sister when they
were fighting right
yes I was asked to support I was just
trying to help
what I thought they both wanted
I was just trying to support or trying
my best to support them the way that I
thought I could